[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros comenzamos nuestra mirada está
hoy en puerto rico- esta pequeña isla
caribeña tiene su destino a merced de
washington son ciudadanos
estadounidenses pero no pueden votar
para elegir a su presidente y tampoco
tienen representante ni senadores en el
capitolio tiene estatus de estado libre
asociado pero no pueden comercializar
con otros países sólo lo hacen con eeuu
el nuevo gobernador aboga para que
puerto rico se convierta en el estado
número 51 de eeuu y que su población
tenga los mismos derechos la llegada de
joe biden a la casa blanca es un signo
de esperanza para ellos y acaban de
elegir a una delegación que defenderá la
causa de la anexión en el capitolio pero
una parte de los habitantes desea tomar
el camino contrario el de la
independencia esta es la historia
i
[Música]
puerto rico le hace honor a su nombre
con su exuberante naturaleza en sus
atractivos turísticos la pequeña isla
caribeña podría ser sinónimo de
abundancia
y sin embargo sus habitantes sueñan con
vivir en otro lugar en 10 años el 12% de
la población ha emigrado la mayoría son
jóvenes
víctor díaz antiguo inspector de fraudes
ahora vive solo aquí
tuvo un gran amor por mi tierra porque
fue el lugar donde yo nací pero el resto
de la familia incluyendo mis hijos está
fuera del turismo está en eeuu porque la
situación está económica pues se los
obligó a emigrar donde quiera que se
mire hay casas vacías almacenes
abandonados con su reducida pensión
víctor lucha por llegar a fin de mes
quería recibir turistas para tener
ingresos extra pero en 2017 en huracán
maría arrasó con todo el tercer piso de
su casa tuvo que empezar de cero
la pensión que tengo este no me no me
cubre las necesidades reales que estoy
recibiendo algunos 961 creo que es que
me sobra al mes necesitaría en realidad
siempre recibir un promedio de 1500
dólares de ingreso para yo poder
subsistir en una forma cómoda no en una
forma lucrativa
[Música]
ya casi no pasan cruceros frente a su
casa desde que empezó la pandemia solo
ve transatlánticos cargados de
mercancías importadas de eeuu con
considerables sobrecostos para víctor el
ambiguo estatus de la isla ni totalmente
parte de eeuu ni libre para gobernarse a
sí misma es insostenible
debemos independizarnos porque hay islas
más pequeñas que nosotros que no tienen
los mismos recursos que nosotros y
sobreviven y les cuesta más pero
sobreviven no no depende de una
inyección económica
justicia y la anexión si no vamos a
hacer estado pues entonces entonces
habrá otro tipo de relación con eeuu
porque hacer un estado directo de la
nación no va a ser una colonia que eeuu
tiene como si fuera es que una inversión
que le procedemos pues este estatus es
en parte responsable del desastre
económico que atraviesa la isla desde
principios de los años 2000 fue una
serie de eventos desafortunados en 2006
el fin de los privilegios fiscales
provocó una fuga masiva de
inversionistas y de empleos en el sector
manufacturero a esto le siguió un plan
de austeridad que provocó el despido de
30.000 funcionarios y el cierre de 400
escuelas y luego dos años de catástrofes
naturales el huracán maría en 2017 y
terremotos en 2019 la isla tiene ahora
una deuda de 70 mil millones de dólares
si quieres seguirles prestando servicios
públicos básicos a sus habitantes tendrá
que devolver el 80 por ciento de esta
cantidad lo antes posible lo cual es
inconcebible por el momento el
gobernador aboga por la plena
integración con eeuu lo que les
permitiría declarar
en quiebra y reestructurar esa deuda
algo que no se les permite hacer por el
momento y para mí
es mucho mejor
el que tengamos todos los derechos que
tienen los ciudadanos americanos
preservando nuestra cultura de nuestro
idioma nuestra manera de ser en primer
lugar tendríamos
5 puertorriqueños o puertorriqueñas en
el congreso dos senadores
y cuatro representantes que estarían
todo el tiempo abogando por puerto rico
la partida no está ganada
una delegación defenderá la causa de la
isla y solicitará formalmente la anexión
en las próximas semanas pero el mal
estado de la economía de puerto rico
podría dificultar el proceso voy a hacer
bien justo
todos los territorios que se
convirtieron en estado
en los últimos 100 150 años sus
economías estaban rezagadas cuando la
comparaba con las de los estados que
pienso que aquí va a ocurrir lo que
ocurrió en hawai en alaska en nuevo
méxico en arizona en la misma florida
cuando esos y esos estados que no eran
estado y los estaban considerando decían
el nuevo méxico es que no hablan el
inglés
es que no están desarrollados de 100 de
florida eso es un pantano pero algunos
no tienen ganas de llamar a la puerta
del tiro sound y rodríguez
buenos días mi gente con los días
estamos a través de radio casa pueblo 10
20 a m la primera emisora comunitaria
ecológica del puerto rico desde adjuntas
pueblo solar en adjuntas en las montañas
centrales la organización casa pueblo
prefiere construir la independencia a
través de una emisora de radio local
la producción de café y verduras pero
sobre todo a través de una batalla por
la independencia energética el objetivo
es hacer que los jóvenes puertorriqueños
tengan ganas de quedarse a diario
porque está
ya estudia literatura y no
si yo quiero trabajar dentro del campo
de estudio no tengo dónde ir y es bien
triste y proyectos como estamos
intentando que sea
gracias a las donaciones de una
fundación y a la participación de
decenas de voluntarios más de 200
edificios incluidos todos los pequeños
comercios del centro de la ciudad
funcionan ahora con energía solar
arturo massol y sus padres iniciaron el
proyecto hace 25 años pero recibió un
gran impulso hace 3 pasa el huracán
maría en el 2017 casa pueblo es el oasis
energético de la comunidad porque opera
con energía solar con energía propia la
gente va allí y conecta a máquinas de
terapias respiratorias recargar sus
equipos y demás ahí casa pueblo
distribuye más de 14.000 lámparas
solares para apoyar a la comunidad con
el tema de iluminación pero la lámpara
solar era para educar a la gente también
de cómo cosechar energía solar y
utilizar la que creemos que el país
puede producir la energía que necesita
para operar y romper la dependencia el
tema de energía es virtualmente un
proceso de auto descolonización en la
plaza del pueblo hay muchos más ancianos
que niños pero el modelo de casa pueblo
se está extendiendo
y lleva se volvieron técnicas en energía
fotovoltaica ahora contemplan su futuro
en adjuntas esto desde ahora esto viene
pasando muchos años ha hecho una
migración bastante grande inclusive
cuando nosotros cogimos el primer la
primera capacitación del enfoque de
ellos es capacitar a la mujer porque
estaba en que la mujer es ese eje
familiar y se apega más al espacio el
hombre se capacita y lamentablemente
muchos de ellos encuentran de que ya no
soy suficiente aquí así es que me tengo
que mover la energía es el sustento de
muchos de los isleños la isla sigue
dependiendo en un 95% de los
combustibles fósiles importados a un
alto precio desde eeuu le cuestan a la
isla dos mil millones de dólares al año
para el invierno
el cambio fue decisivo para adjunta para
todo puerto rico es muy costosa y en
algunos casos
el punto clave para que un negocio cese
las operaciones tengo compañeros de
negocios que pagan cinco meses a emails
ya de e-mail ahora el restaurante de
liberto se autoabastece de energía lo
que le ha permitido resistir los malos
tiempos del cob y 19 pero por lo demás
eeuu sigue presente en todas partes
puerto rico solo produce el 15 por
ciento de los alimentos que consumen sus
habitantes el resto viene de eeuu y
cuesta un 40% más que en el continente a
la isla no se le permite mantener
relaciones comerciales con otros países
por no poner la leche por ejemplo este
es medio galón de leche aquí por torrico
nos cuesta un promedio de 3 dólares con
6 centavos
eeuu debe estar en un promedio de entre
125 a 155 cosas en realidad nos traen un
montón de cosas que son importadas de
estados unidos o son productos que
vienen del extranjero entra en eeuu y
después vienen para acá y entiendo pues
que pagamos doble impuesto porque eeuu
le cobra impuestos a la nación que
quiere vender más le cobra el impuesto a
puntos diseños otra vez o para acá
porque hay unos gastos que hay que son
bien altos que son cubrir los gastos de
la naviera precios que están por las
nubes mientras que el 42% de los
habitantes viven por debajo del umbral
de la pobreza hace 20 años puerto rico
era el quinto productor mundial de
productos farmacéuticos pero el fin de
los privilegios fiscales para las
empresas en 2006 provocó un colapso de
la actividad
carmen sara team y trabajó como
directora de producto en la planta de
glaxosmithkline en sidra desde 1976 a
2009 la empresa representó toda su
carrera
la compañía aportaba mucho al pueblo a
la sociedad
la compañía ayudaba mucho a las escuelas
la compañía en el tiempo del verano
abría sus puertas para los estudiantes
que trabajarán en el verano si nos cogió
de sorpresa nosotros teníamos 11 mega
lanzamientos de medicamentos pues que
clarkson cierra esto empezamos a ver
cómo de las plantas sólidas
estaban cerrando
una serie de crisis que llevó a los
puertorriqueños al límite en 2019
salieron a las calles en masa varios
escándalos de corrupción habían sacudido
poco antes la esfera política así que
cuando se filtraron conversaciones en
las que el gobernador de entonces se un
lado de las víctimas del huracán la ira
de la gente estalló aiola virella cubrió
de cerca a este movimiento para su
periódico eran expresiones muy fuertes
así que esta movilización era
específicamente occidente para que se
identificaba específicamente la figura
del gobierno local este episodio sin
precedentes en la historia de la isla
exacerbó las tensiones entre los
partidarios de la adicción a eeuu y los
del movimiento independentista en
general en puerto rico- creo que más de
más del 50 por ciento de las personas
piensan que es necesario una presencia
de eeuu es necesaria esa relación para
garantizar nuestro nuestro bienestar
económico y nuestro sistema verdad que
no sea un sistema corrupto creo que hay
una generación de puertorriqueños
verdad una generación que está subiendo
que es una generación que no vivió
la bonanza no tenemos unos jóvenes que
han vivido crisis de corrupción que han
vivido los huracanes que han vivido los
terremotos que han vivido ahora la
pandemia y que es unos jóvenes que
realmente no no ven cómo esta
dependencia de que de que nosotros no
podríamos echar hacia adelante por
nosotros mismos desde eeuu la única
opción para la prosperidad o un falso
aliado perjudicial muchos vieron la
visita de donald trump en 2017 un gesto
simbólico de la actitud de eeuu hacia
los puertorriqueños mientras el caribe
quedó devastado por el huracán maría el
mandatario lanzó rollos de toallas de
papel a los damnificados mientras los
acusaba de costarle demasiado al
gobierno federal vino como para promover
su figura pero eso no se fue todo lo
inverso
porque al tirar los rollos de papel de
papel sanitario resultó el
puertorriqueño a lo tomo como una falta
de respeto siempre en tensión entre
quedarse o irse
víctor y sus compatriotas siguen a
merced de un futuro incierto me quedo
aquí porque de momento entiendo que no
tengo la capacidad para irme para allá
y posteriormente pues según vea que me
mejore en alguna forma la condición del
país para lo mejor me quedo pero si no
mejora y sigue empeorando pues yo creo
que para yo poder vivir mejor y tener
una vida de más calidad allá es mejor
que yo
pero el statu quo no será fácil de
romper hay muy pocos argumentos para
convencer a washington de la adicción
muy poco apoyo de los puertorriqueños al
proyecto independentista por el momento
puerto rico sigue aficionado en su
estatus de estado libre asociado ni
realmente libre ni realmente asociados
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerden que pueden
ingresar a nuestra página web france24
puntocom para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]